will be presenting her dissertation
proposal today
and her title is a novel computational
framework for inferring the
Developmental and cellular origins of
rare and congenital disorders using
single cell RNA and sequencing data and
just a little background about Jennifer
she is a PhD candidate in our BCB
program on the National Library of
Medicine Fellowship she is dedicated to
uncovering the biological mechanisms of
rare and congenital disorders including
her own condition AMC during her early
years at OHSU Jennifer found herself
drawn to single cell RNA sequencing data
and its utility in studying
developmental biology she is now excited
to combine single cell analysis with
systems biology approaches to get to the
root of congenital and rare disorders I
should also comment that she last June
won the best paper presentation at the
nlm trainee meeting so congratulations
and welcome Jennifer
thank you Karen thank you for that very
nice introduction
um yeah so uh thank you all for
attending my dissertation proposal
defense
um as Karen stated I will be proposing a
novel computational framework for
inferring the Developmental and cellular
origins of rare and congenital disorders
using single cell rna-seq data
oops
one second
okay
so I will Begin by providing some
background on approaches for
understanding the
I'm sorry my screen is doing something
weird one second
okay it's coming through on our end and
it looks just fine okay thanks yeah I
think it's working now
um so I will Begin by providing some
background on approaches for
understanding the etiology of disorders
and on Opera on understand on
opportunities for improvement excuse me
I will then present our proposed project
starting with our specific aims I will
then discuss various aspects of our
research approach I will also talk about
the innovation of our project
and finally I will touch on future
directions and give my concluding
statements
so let's get started with the research
question and what the state of the field
looks like so far
263 to 446 million people three and a
half to six percent of the global
population are affected by a rare
disorder
yet over 90 percent of the estimated 7
000 rare disorders still do not have any
FDA approved treatments
congenital disorders affect over 5
million people born each year worldwide
are the leading cause of infant deaths
and frequently results in lifelong
disability
yet the cause of most congenital
disorders is still unknown
these two patient populations exemplify
a strong need for Research into disease
etiology that can inform ways to develop
treatments
in many cases efforts to uncover the
etiology of these disorders has been
impeded by the Limited availability of
patient samples either due to the small
number of patients with a given disorder
or to the inaccessibility of the
relevant tissues during the initial
stages of the disease process
therefore for these disorders and for
others with similar challenges we need
new approaches for determining their
pathogenesis that do not rely on the
collection of disease-specific data
one important question that still needs
to be answered for many of these
disorders is which cell types are
implicated in initiating the disease
process
in other words what is their root cause
at the cellular level
when considering mendelian disorders for
example the vast majority are believed
to manifest in one or just a few tissues
however in many cases we don't know
which cell types within those tissues
are actually driving the disorder
in addition many disorders are caused by
cellular disruptions that originate
before birth
therefore another crucial question is
what stage of development these cells
are in when their functioning is
disrupted
given this observation that disorders
manifest in a small number of tissues a
natural assumption might be that the
gene responsible for a given disorder is
only expressed in those affected tissues
or is expressed at a much higher level
than in other tissues
although this is the case for some
disease genes it turns out that this is
not the whole story
in fact most genes are expressed in at
least 10 tissues and an estimated 72
percent of these genes are expressed at
similar levels and disease-associated
and non-disease-associated tissues
so this means that we really need to
look at more than just the expression
level of a disease Gene to determine
which cell types play a role in the
development of each disorder
in fact there are several reasons why a
mutated Gene May initiate a disease
process in one cell type but not another
for our project we will be focusing on
the mechanisms involving disruptions of
the molecular networks specific to each
cell type
these will include both cell autonomous
or so intrinsic networks and non-so
autonomous or so extrinsic Networks
in particular I will concentrate on this
concept of Gene module Integrity
specifically modules of disease genes to
identify the cells and developmental
stages implicated in various disorders
so let's talk about disease modules
defined a disease module as a group of
network components that together
contribute to a cellular function whose
disruption results in a particular
disease phenotype
in other words a disease module
represents the concept that proteins and
other molecules associated with the
disease phenotype are not scattered
randomly throughout the network but
instead cluster into modules
it is not the impact of a mutation on a
single Gene but the impact of a mutated
gene on this entire module that produces
the disease phenotype
this idea of a disease module was based
on observations from various studies
such as that performed by go at all who
overlapped a disease Gene network with a
protein-protein interaction Network and
saw 10 times more physical interactions
between proteins associated with the
same disorder than would be expected by
chance
since then many Studies have
demonstrated the feasibility of
identifying disease modules
one notable study performed by mencha at
all revealed that out of nearly 300
disorders investigated
226 were associated with sets of disease
genes that clustered together into a
neighborhood of the molecular Network as
shown here for multiple sclerosis
however the network used by mencha at
all and by many other studies is a
generic Network meaning it is not
specific to a given tissue or cell type
if we are to identify the cell types
involved in producing disease we will
need to discover what the molecular
networks look like Within These
individual cell types
a few Studies have made steps toward
uncovering these cell type specific
networks starting with kitsuck at all
by inferring tissue specific networks
they were able to identify an average of
just two to three tissues implicated in
half of the disorders they investigated
with the growing availability of single
cell data sets there is now opportunity
to identify the individual cell types
that initiate disease
for example muhammadi at all used their
method Skynet to infer cell
type-specific protein-protein
interaction Networks
and use these networks to infer the cell
types that initiated three classes of
brain disorders
what they found was that there was a
clear distinction between the disease
classes based on which cell types were
targeted with psychiatric disorders
manifesting primarily in neuronal cell
types and neurodegenerative and
neoplastic disorders manifesting
primarily in glial cell types
a similar analysis on autoimmune
disorders revealed disease modules in
blood cell types but not brain cell
types again confirming what would be
expected
these studies demonstrate the apparent
feasibility of identifying pathogenic
cell types through disease module
detection
however a number of gaps still need to
be addressed to improve the inference of
these cell types of these cell types
the first Gap is that the networks used
for these analyzes are restricted to
interactions that have been
experimentally determined
this set of known interactions is likely
missing a large proportion of the true
interactions taking place
and these incomplete interactoms may not
provide adequate information to discover
disease modules
in addition these known interactions are
biased toward well-studied genes and
proteins meaning these molecules are
more likely to form hubs in the
constructed Network simply due to the
larger number of studies focused on them
this bias can also affect the accuracy
of the inferred networks and hinder the
discovery of disease modules
the second Gap is the need for stronger
evidence to support these inferred cell
type-specific interactions
previous Studies have relied on the
assumption that as long as both
Neighbors in the network are expressed
above a certain level they must interact
however as this figure illustrates there
are a number of biological reasons why
this assumption is not always valid
therefore other strategies that provide
stronger evidence of the inferred
interactions could improve the accuracy
of the networks and the inference of
disease modules and pathogenic cell
types
the third Gap that remains unfilled is
the need for a method that can infer
pairs of cell types whose disrupted
communication results in disease
communication between cells is crucial
for the proper development maintenance
and function of cell types and
disruption of specific communication
activities can result in specific
phenotypes well methods do exist for the
inference of cell cell communication
they do not specifically identify which
communicating cell types are relevant
for each phenotype
so far no study that is specifically
designed for the inference of pathogenic
cell types has addressed this issue
the fourth Gap that should be addressed
is the need for a pathogenic cell type
inference method that can infer multiple
disease modules and individual cell
types
a single phenotype can result from
multiple molecular processes even within
a single cell type
therefore its genes may form multiple
modules in each affected cell type
so far Studies have evaluated
the connectivity of either all of the
disease genes mapped to the network or
only the disease genes that form a
connected component
in either case the power to detect
significant modules of disease genes is
lower than if the separate modules were
each inferred and assessed individually
finally the fifth Gap is the need for a
method to infer the developmental stages
at which the pathogenic cells are most
likely affected
knowing these developmental stages is
critical for understanding the etiology
of a disease as experimental studies can
be targeted to these periods of
sensitivity
in addition this knowledge can inform
the development of treatments indicating
both the necessary timing of treatment
Administration such as in utero or X
utero and the nature of the treatment
itself
the approach that we propose will
address each of these opportunities for
improvement
so let's get into our proposed project
starting with our objective hypothesis
and specific aims
the objective of our proposed project is
to provide a novel computational
approach to investigate the cellular
origins of disease
in other words our project aims to
understand the root cause of diseases at
the cellular level
our hypothesis is that the observed cell
type specificity of a phenotype is the
result of the disruption of normal
molecular processes that are specific to
a limited set of cell types at
particular developmental stages
the two aims for our project take
complementary approaches for identifying
pathogenic cell types and developmental
stages
our first aim focuses on developing a
novel computational approach for
inferring de novo intrinsic processes
happening within the cells
well our second aim focuses on
developing such an approach to infer the
extrinsic communication processes
between cells
now let's dig into the details first I
will present our proposed computational
framework
this figure illustrates our overall
workflow we will develop a dedicated
approach to address each of our aims as
illustrated by the steps above an orange
frame one and the steps Below in blue
for aim2
while the detailed steps of these
processes will differ they will share
the same high-level workflow as they
provide complementary information about
the pathogenic cell types
the pipelines we develop will require
two inputs single cell rnac data and a
set of disease genes
they will first infer sulfate
trajectories then construct cell type
specific Networks
they will then identify modules of
disease genes in each of these Networks
and they will output the pathogenic cell
types at the impacted developmental
stages
with this overall picture of the high
level framework
I will go into more detail about each
step
again our computational framework will
require two inputs
one of these inputs will be a single
cell rna-seq Atlas collected from normal
healthy tissues over multiple stages of
development
our motivation for using data from
healthy tissues rather than diseased
tissues is twofold
first it eliminates the need for
disease-specific data enabling the use
of our approach on a wide array of
disorders
second healthy tissues provide a window
into normal molecular processes without
being obstructed by the downstream
effects of a disease process
because the aim of our project is to
investigate the root causes of diseases
our computational framework will use
this insight into healthy molecular
processes to identify which of these are
disrupted in the disease state
stable lists examples of large single
cell rna-seq atlases that provide data
for multiple tissues over various
developmental stages
our approach will be designed to use
these large multi-tissue atlases as well
as atlases focused more specifically on
the development of an individual tissue
the second input will be a set of genes
that are causally associated with the
particular phenotype because most rare
and congenital disorders are associated
with a single Gene that cannot be used
on their own to identify disease modules
by focusing on a phenotype shared by
multiple disorders we can pool all of
their genes together
for example congenital contractures more
formally known as arthrogryposis
Multiplex congenita
is a phenotype that is seen in over 400
disorders most of these disorders appear
to be monogenic and therefore cannot be
used on their own to identify disease
modules however this group of disorders
is associated with over 400 genes and
this set of genes could form disease
modules
with our strategy of investigating
phenotypes rather than individual
diseases we eliminate the need to know
the causal Gene for any single disorder
therefore this strategy facilitates the
investigation into the etiology even of
disorders that remain undiagnosed
to supply the gene set for a particular
phenotype users of our computational
framework will have two options
they can either Supply their own Gene
set or they can select a term from the
human phenotype ontology
this hierarchically structured database
of over 15 000 phenotype terms has been
linked to over fifteen thousand genes
from the genotype ontology
users will be able to select the genes
associated with a specific phenotype
term
as well as add to or subtract from this
set
our strategy of combining diseases based
on phenotypes is just one of multiple
strategies
one of multiple possible strategies for
grouping disorders
because our Gene sets will be
constructed according to their
association with a specific phenotype we
propose the term phenotype module where
the modules inferred through our
computational framework rather than
disease module as we believe this to be
a more precise and descriptive term
the first step in our computational
framework will offer users context to
understand the stage at which cells
exist when they are impacted relative to
the other cell types in the data set
the position of the impacted cell types
and the inferred sulfate trajectories
will indicate the cell's putative
progenitors and potential sulfates
to infer these trajectories our workflow
will use the monocle 3 software as it
was designed to reproduce complex
branching trajectories that can
originate from multiple progenitors
our workflow will then need to infer the
cell type specific networks for every
cell type in the data set
this is the primary step where the
approaches for the two aims diverge so I
will talk about each of their workflows
independently
for aim one our computational approach
will be to infer a de novo Gene
regulatory Network for each cell type
the construction of such a network will
rely on discovering related patterns of
expression between genes
however single cell data is notoriously
noisy and cells of the same type have
relatively similar transcriptional
profiles
therefore the signal of the true
regulatory activities playing out in an
individual cell type will likely be
masked by the noisiness of the data
therefore rather than directly inferring
a gene regulatory Network for each cell
type we will use a more more robust
approach
first our approach will be to learn all
of the regulatory patterns that
characterize the entire data set
resulting in a generic Gene regulatory
Network
then our computational pipeline will use
this learned Network as the starting
structure from which to infer each cell
type-specific network
the workflow that we have developed for
inferring these networks is based on
that of the popular high Scenic workflow
as I discuss our workflow I will point
out how and why it differs from piscenic
to obtain the generic Gene regulatory
Network for the full data set we will
first infer an initial network of
potential regulatory relationships using
a method called grn boost 2.
this initial step simply identifies
correlated expression patterns between
all of the genes
therefore this first step will produce a
densely connected network with many
false edges and we will need to refine
this network to isolate the true
regulatory relationships
in this illustration the thin arrows
represent true interactions inferred by
grn Boost 2. whereas the Bold arrows
represent false edges
when inferring the regulatory Network we
need to find the interactions that
represent the direct influence of a
transcription Factor on its Target Gene
in other words we want to eliminate any
link between transcription factor and
Gene that is mediated by at least one
other transcription Factor
therefore we will use sys Target to
identify these direct interactions
or transcription factor to directly
regulate a gene it must be able to bind
to the genes of CIS regulatory elements
this target makes use of sequence Motif
data to remove any of the transcription
factors inferred targets whose CIS
regulatory elements are not sufficiently
enriched for the transcription factors
binding motif
in this illustration the Red Arrows
represent inferred transcription Factor
Target Gene relationships that have low
likelihood of direct interaction due to
the low enrichment of the transcription
factors binding motifs
these edges will be removed in this step
the remaining false edges are now
colored red
each Edge represents a correlated
transcription factor and Target Gene
where the target genes CIS regulatory
elements are enriched for the
transcription factors binding motifs
this means that in theory the
transcription Factor could directly
regulate the target Gene
however whether this regulation actually
happens within the cells in the data set
is still in question
one way to eliminate correlations that
do not represent true causation is to
investigate the relative timing of
expression for both transcription factor
and putative Target Gene
when given RNA velocity calculations
scribe and infer the degree to which one
Gene's expression level over time
provides information about another
Gene's expression level at subsequent
time points
therefore we will use scribe along with
SC Bellow to infer the putative causal
regulatory interactions and eliminate
any edges that are not well supported
well the first two steps in our workflow
are also implemented in the pi Scenic
workflow this step to infer the putative
causal relationships is an addition that
we believe will further improve the
inference of the generic Gene regulatory
Network
by following these three steps we expect
to construct a network that is
representative of the direct causal
regulatory relationships present in the
full data set
the next task will be to infer the
interactions within this generic Gene
regulatory Network that are active in
each individual cell type
to infer each cell type specific Gene
regulatory Network we will first infer
which regulons from the full Network are
active in the given cell type using the
aucl enrichment method implemented in pi
scenic
rather than simply inferring individual
interactions based on the expression
levels of transcription factor and
Target Gene Au cell provides greater
support for each inferred interaction
this is because it uses the fact that a
regular represents a group of
co-regulated genes
and therefore the target genes in an
activated regulon should all be
upregulated at the same time
the active regulons that are inferred
through this enrichment step may not be
connected to one another
therefore our workflow will also use
these regulons as anchors for random
walks through the full Network in order
to infer the paths between them
to guide these random walks based on
cell type specificity our pipeline will
weight the genes in the network by their
differential expression compared to all
other cell types in the data set
at the end of step two we should have a
connected set of regulons for each cell
type in the data set that represents
that cell types specific Gene regulatory
Network
so now let's go through the network
construction step for aim2 in this case
we will be inferring a cell cell
communication Network for each pair of
cell types
again we will break this network
inference step down into two tasks
in the first task we will again
construct a generic Network This Time by
integrating prior knowledge of protein
protein interactions
we will then use this network as the
basis to infer the cell cell
communication Network for every pair of
cell types
to form the scaffolds for a cell
pair-specific communication networks our
pipeline will pull the protein protein
interactions stored in the omnipath the
knowledge base
omnipath provides over a hundred
thousand protein protein interactions
including over 14 000 interactions
between intercellular signaling
molecules which are referred to as
transmitters and receivers
from the interactions in omnipath we
will construct a generic cell cell
communication Network that contains
transmitter receiver Pairs and their
Downstream signaling pathways
in addition because proteins Upstream of
the transmitters and receivers can
influence their activity
we will also integrate these Upstream
protein protein interactions
once this generic communication network
is constructed we can begin to infer the
communication Network specific to each
cell type pair
the first step in inferring the
communication Network for a particular
pair of cell types will be to narrow
down the initial set of transmitter
receiver pairs
we will be using cell trap which
incorporates information about both
protein complex formation and agonists
and antagonists to refine its
predictions
for example if a receiver must form a
complex to function but one of the
components of the complex is not
expressed the receiver and its
Associated transmitter will not be
included in the network
the next step is to infer the downstream
signaling pathways
we will infer these Pathways using Niche
net
Niche net uses an optimized random walk
with restart to Traverse signaling
pathways
beginning at each transmitter traversing
through the bound receiver signaling
proteins transcription factors and
ending at the regulated Target genes
based on these random walks nishna
infers the putative Downstream targets
of a cell cell signaling event and in
the process the putative signaling
Pathways that mediate this regulation
thus we will use Niche Net's predictions
to retain the most likely signaling
Pathways and to filter out the rest
at this point we can use these inferred
intracellular intracellular signaling
Pathways to further refine the network
of transmitter receiver pairs
this time we will start with the target
genes
these genes are predicted by Niche net
to be actively regulated in the receiver
cell type
therefore we will compare the target
genes in each of these regulons with the
genes that are actually differentially
expressed in this cell type compared to
all others
if a predicted set of Target genes has
low correlation with the actual
differentially expressed genes its
Associated signaling pathway will be
removed
on the other hand if another regulon's
predicted genes have a strong
correlation with the cell types
differentially expressed genes that will
provide a high level of support for
retaining the entire Associated pathway
including the initiating transmitter
receiver pair
so finally we will infer the Upstream
protein protein interactions
because each gene has a different
Baseline level of expression we will
create a baseline distribution of
average expression values for each gene
by randomly sampling subsets of cells
we will then compare each Gene's
expression level in each cell type to
its Baseline distribution to determine
its statistical significance
any Gene with expression below a
significance threshold will be filtered
out of the network
at the end of step two we should have a
cell cell communication Network for
every pair of cell types
with the networks constructed we can
then move on to step three where our
computational framework will infer the
modules of phenotype Associated genes
this step will require three subtasks
mapping the phenotype Associated genes
onto the network searching for phenotype
modules and evaluating the statistical
significance of each phenotype module
the first step is to map the genes
associated with a particular phenotype
onto each cell type specific Network
these genes will be assigned a higher
weight than the other genes which will
help to guide the detection of phenotype
modules in the next step
because the phenotype may arise from
multiple molecular processes within the
same cell type our pipeline will search
for the optimal partitioning of the
disease genes mapped to each Network
to determine this partitioning we'll be
using a module inference method called
hierarchical hotneck
we selected this method for two reasons
first it is able to use the higher
weights of the of the disease genes to
guide its partitioning procedure
and second it explores different
hierarchical levels of network
resolution which has been shown to
improve the inference of modules of
disease genes
with the disease genes partitioned we
can now evaluate the significance of the
connectedness and size of each module
for aim1 the connectivity of each module
will be assessed based on the average
shortest distance between the disease
genes themselves
in AIM 2 however we specifically want to
identify the phenotype modules that
impact cell cell communication
therefore our approach for aim2 will be
to assess the connectivity of the
phenotype modules in relation to the
transmitters and receivers in the cell
self-communication network
at the end of our computational
framework we expect to see a subset of
cell types at particular stages of
development that can be associated with
the phenotype of Interest based on the
presence of statistically significant
phenotype modules
since our second aim is devoted to
inferring communication relationships
the cell types will be output in pairs
indicating the necessity of
communication between these cell types
to prevent the development of the
phenotype
most of the methods we'll be using have
adjustable settings that need to be
optimized for our purpose of pathogenic
cell type inference
these are the hyper parameters of our
pipelines and I will now talk about how
we plan to optimize these hyper
parameters
as I highlighted at the beginning of my
talk the number of phenotypes for which
we know the causal cell types and
disrupted developmental stages is still
Limited therefore to make sure we have
enough data to optimize the hyper
parameters of our pipelines we will be
using simulated data sets
for our project there are two elements
that need to be simulated single cell
rna-seq atlases and sets of disease
genes for a given phenotype
sorry it's proven
it's is it changing on your end up here
we go
okay I don't know what happened
um
okay to simulate the Single Cell rna-seq
atlases we will be using a simulation
method called wool ode
this method is based on Gene netweaver
which was used to generate the synthetic
networks for the dream 3 dream 4 and
dream 5 challenges for transcriptional
Network inference
these methods begin with a known Gene
regulatory Network on which they sample
sub Networks
they then use these known subnetworks
along with a set of differential
equations to model transcriptional
events in each cell
from these models these methods produce
a data set of cells with simulated
expression values
we will cluster these stimulated cells
using the popular Laden clustering
algorithm
the next step is to simulate the sets of
disease genes associated with
hypothetical phenotypes
these simulated Gene sets will need to
be selected in such a way that they will
form genotype modules in a subset of
cell clusters
therefore we will select a small subset
of simulated cell types in which to
construct hypothetical phenotype modules
for aim one the genes in each phenotype
module should cluster together in the
gene regulatory Network
therefore we will construct each
phenotype module by identifying a
connected group of genes in one of the
simulated Gene Regulatory subnetworks
and assigning these genes to that module
for aim two we will follow a similar
procedure however in this case rather
than searching for phenotype modules in
gene regulatory networks our pipeline
will need to search for phenotype
modules in cell cell communication
Networks
therefore to construct the hypothetical
phenotype modules we will collect sets
of genes known to participate in real
cell communication pathways
we will then simulate higher
transcription of these genes in the
pathogenic cell clusters
to optimize our pipeline's hyper
parameters we will test multiple
combinations of values on our simulated
data sets the performance using each
combination of hyper parameters will be
evaluated based on our pipeline's
ability to identify the correct
pathogenic cell clusters as determined
by the area under the Precision recall
curve
once the settings for our computational
pipelines have been determined we will
assess their final performance on a new
data set
this time we will test our approach on
real phenotypes
on the left are our criteria for
selecting phenotypes to use in our
evaluation
the phenotypes we select will have well
understood etiology with a core set of
causal cell types and molecular
processes that are activated at known
stages of developments
in addition they will have a set of
associated disease genes that are
enriched for these molecular pathways
finally the pathogenic cell types and
developmental stages must be represented
in available data sets
the table on the right shows examples of
phenotypes selected as candidates for
evaluating our approach
when considering the data sets we will
be using to assess to assess performance
we must remember that our objective is
to pinpoint the earliest processes that
trigger the initiation of a phenotype
the process of development is what sets
the stage for normal physiological
functioning and most of this development
occurs in utero
therefore even if a phenotype doesn't
present itself until childhood or
adulthood the molecular processes
underlying that phenotype are typically
already established usually before birth
to detect these early developmental
processes we will primarily use datasets
sampled during in utero development
such as these data sets from Mouse
embryonic development and human fetal
development
using the selected phenotypes and single
cell data sets we will evaluate our
pipeline's abilities to correctly
identify the phenotype's known
pathogenic cell types and developmental
stages
we will also assess their ability to
rank their Associated cell types and
stages above others
along with this direct evaluation we
will assess additional criteria to
support our pipeline's ability to
uncover meaningful biology
specifically we will assess the
enrichment of phenotype modules for
known molecular Pathways and for disease
genes held out of the mapped Gene set
to evaluate the robustness of our
approach we will test its performance on
different data sets such as human and
mouse data sets or multi-tissue and
tissue specific data sets
for each of these assessment approaches
we will compare our approach to that
used in the Skynet paper
we expect that our method will be able
to identify additional Regulatory and
cell cell communication relationships
that will improve the inference of
implicated cell types and developmental
stages
upon evaluating our pipeline's
performance we may find that we need to
try alternative approaches I will
discuss some of the other methods that
we will use if our initial approach
produces poorer results
the success of our pipelines depends on
their ability to accurately infer the
cell type specific networks and
phenotype modules
therefore our alternative approaches
focus on inferring these networks and
modules in different ways
one approach for aim one will be to
infer the generic Gene regulatory
network using scode
which is able to take into account the
temporal information that is provided by
the inference of the sulfate
trajectories
for aim2 we will use an alternative
method called log FC mean for inferring
the transmitter receiver pairs
communicating between cell types this
method outperformed all other methods on
one of the cell cell communication tests
in a recent evaluation
for both of our aims we will also
construct the networks through a waiting
procedure rather than filtering out
interactions with insufficient support
these weights will then be used in
detecting phenotype modules
and finally we will try an alternative
module detection method
unlike hierarchical hot net which
assumes that the boundaries of the true
phenotype modules are best defined by
the distribution of the known disease
genes the popular Laden clustering
algorithm considers only the topology of
the network
therefore the latent algorithm will not
be influenced by our current knowledge
of disease genes and any bias that the
incomplete Gene set May introduce
so now that I have described a research
approach I will highlight the Innovative
aspects of our proposed project
our project will address each of the
gaps described earlier
specifically rather than restricting our
generic Gene regulatory Network to known
interactions we will have developed a
novel workflow to infer de novo cell
type-specific Gene regulatory networks
from the data itself
this will afford US the opportunity to
discover previously unknown regulatory
interactions and allow us to
dramatically reduce the bias toward
well-studied genes
in addition cell type specific
interactions will be inferred using
systems level approaches reducing the
Reliance on the assumption that two
neighboring genes interact if they are
both expressed
we will also have developed a method to
infer pairs of pathogenic cell types
whose disrupted interaction can produce
the given phenotype to our knowledge no
other study has attempted to identify
these relationships
our pipelines are also the first to use
a module detection method to infer
multiple phenotype modules in individual
cell types
the inference of each individual
phenotype module should increase our
power to detect significantly connected
groups of diseased genes
and finally our pipeline will have
built-in functionality for analyzing the
temporal components of pathogenesis
enabling investigation of the stages of
development at which the relevant
disruptions occur
an exciting aspect of our proposed
project is that it opens the door to
many additional types of studies I will
next talk briefly about potential future
directions of our work
the purpose of our project is to
generate new hypotheses about the
cellular origins of disease
therefore a clear research direction
would be to experimentally investigate
the results of our approach for various
phenotypes
in addition our project can be a
stepping stone for other types of
computational analyzes such as the
development of a disease Gene prediction
method informed by the networks of the
predicted cell types and stages
the integration of our networks and
phenotype modules with environmental
exposure data to investigate
environmental disease mechanisms
and the prediction of Downstream effects
of the perturbed cell types on cellular
development and function
so I have talked about the need to
understand the etiology of rare and
congenital disorders and I have proposed
a novel project to identify the root
causes of disease at the cellular level
I'll now wrap up with some final
thoughts
at the completion of this project we
will have provided a computational
approach for the inference of pathogenic
cell types and developmental stages we
anticipate that our approach will
provide complementary information about
the connections between the phenotype
Associated genes and we plan to
integrate the de novo cell type specific
Gene regulatory networks with the cell
cell communication networks to assess
whether these complementary
relationships can improve the inference
of pathogenic cell types
our project provides an opportunity to
study disease etiology for rare
congenital and other disorders without
requiring inaccessible tissue samples
from large patient cohorts
in the long term the insights provided
by this approach should facilitate the
developments of precision treatments
that are targeted to the cell types and
molecular processes specifically
disrupted in each disorder
this table shows the estimated time to
complete the various steps of our
project
and I would like to thank the members of
my committee for guiding me through this
process and offering their feedback and
suggestions and I would also like to
thank my fellow students for their
feedback and support and finally I thank
all of you for attending my proposal
defense and with that I can take any
questions
thank you Jennifer
we have about
seven eight minutes maybe 10 minutes for
the the larger group to ask questions
and then we will
um all of us will leave except for the
committee and Jennifer to to finish up
their discussions
so I have a question I think
um my sense is that this approach then
could be applied to other conditions as
well so this is a methodology
um
what you're really establishing is new
methodology and new approaches
yes correct yeah and I I agree that this
can go even Beyond rare and congenital
disorders the more common disorders I
mean
yeah um
almost anything
um I think you know if you were
going to study I think the you know this
this especially applies to disorders you
know a development whether that's in
utero or work with needle
um but I think
it possibly if you had the right data
sets you could maybe study this and you
know like uh infectious diseases or
something right like that if you have
like an actual data set that you know is
maybe in some animal model or something
where you infect and then you kind of
you know
track the development of the disease
after infection as well so you have this
kind of multiple time points I think
this could maybe be applied to that as
well
okay thank you
maybe take your slide down so we can see
if anybody's got their hand up I can
only see four images on this gotcha
there we go
so I'll ask a question and and I I too
am no expert in this area but you know I
was
um I was thinking as you in the
beginning of your talk you were talking
about how um
um oftentimes we we build models Based
on data based on incomplete data which
certainly those of us on the clinical
side
um deal with that you know you know
because for example we only know about
patients what's in the electronic health
record which is
somewhat complete of a picture but not
always complete and actually if you
think about other machine learning
methods even outside of medicine
um you know we build these huge models
but really based on the world as we
represent it so I guess my question to
you without knowing a real lot of the
details of of your work is Will Will
these new methods give you enough
additional data to kind of push the
needle on on building these uh disease
modules more effectively and then
actually lead to the kind of um
improvements in our understanding that
Karen was alluding to
yeah
um that's a good question
um I think that'll remain to be seen I'm
hoping so
um I I think you know by for example
when we're inferring to Novo Gene
regulatory networks
um you know again that's not something
that anyone has done before for this
purpose
um and so I think you know as I was kind
of talking about in the in my
presentation it will offer opportunities
to discover other
um interactions that we don't know about
and you know our prior knowledge
um you know one possibility is to
combine this method with prior you know
the prior knowledge networks you know
and see if that improves things as well
right
um uh you know that's sort of what we're
doing with you know at the end when I
talked about combining the inferred Novo
Gene regulatory networks with the cell
self communication networks you know
those are based on known protein protein
interaction networks um and so we're
hoping that you know by com combining
those two
um you know we will be able to discover
interactions that are
already discoverable from the known
networks and then also new ones that we
can discover by our inference methods to
answer the question
yeah well like you say well
um your your work will hopefully give us
answers to that
if there's other questions out there
from the larger audience feel free to
unmute and ask a question
I think this was a great presentation I
know I learned quite a bit from watching
it so thank you for being so clear and
stepping me through your work and and
very important work so at this time
anyone who's part of the committee and
the educational team that's going to be
staying on the rest of us can go ahead
and and step off and have a couple more
minutes before your next meeting
thank you thank you thanks